and one apologies now do we have any uh
apologies
no are we are we fully here everybody
oh it doesn't matter dan's all right oh
okay
we'll just leave that in a balance so
we'll move on to
item two conflicts of interest any of
those full minuting
no all right conf
item three confirmation of minutes
minutes of the
meeting of 21st of july pages 6
to 18 on your agenda
any alterations
for accuracy
no all right um i will
move them and counselor atkinson is
quite happy to second them
um all those i'll put that that we
accept
we confirm the circulated minutes of
july the 21st is a true and accurate
record all those in favor please say aye
against the cleric carried
matters arising i thought there were
some matters arising
what was i going to
uh yes there was i think councillor
williams
uh uh maybe i'll leave it
yeah um martin pinkham's name is spelt
incorrectly
in fact that's around the other way
martin is i n
and martin cook is y in
yes just some there was something i was
going to meet her
it doesn't matter
all right um okay uh
matters are rising no matters rising
apart from those um
those spelling um corrections
uh item four is a presentation and
deputation now we have
barry cuttings from oxford promotion
association
due to present us with an annual report
but he doesn't appear to
have appeared um i presume he knows
where to come
he does okay well
we'll just leave that in the balance if
if mr cuttings turns up then we can
we can slot him in somewhere can't we
right
so we'll just move on to item five which
is
um the audit new zealand
interim audit report for the year june
30th
and mr millwood will take us through it
thank you
thank you um so this is the interim
report
the final reports will be presented
[Music]
after the audit and
annual report has been adopted in
october
so they'll come around about late
november probably to the december
meeting for the final one
basically there were three areas that
they
found we could improve and this one was
and it was around reconciliations around
covert time
uh they weren't done in a timely manner
which has been corrected uh there was
review
uh before person terminates
we've got to be the more timely in that
in terms of taking off the
access to systems and so forth so that's
been corrected
and there's the impairment of any assets
and the one that they identified was the
rangiora
service center building which was around
about
350 ah so it was
forget the number but it was not
significant we haven't impaired it
we'll be just expensing that value
and that's the bit we were fixing the
marine
mesh sorry the steel mesh 663 steel mesh
so normally you would actually do an
impairment you'd write down the asset
and then when it's corrected you would
um revalue the asset back to where it
was
in this instance we've just left it on
the box you'll never notice it
within the it's a
it's a two month or three month
action which doesn't provide you any
benefit at all
so that's the three that they've
identified there's some
outstanding ones that you'll probably
notice on the audit report
which have hit to be signed off
the one that which is probably going to
reappear
is a note on vested assets so once again
we've
found that we've got double counting and
invested assets that goes back to 2014.
that was a time when we transferred a
lot of our assets across
and there was a fair bit of activity
going through the accounts
post earthquake and we double counted
uh assets within the roading account in
the
drainage account and that's been since
corrected
i can't guarantee that we won't find
more
vested assets but what we are finding
doesn't have any
significance of some of the effect on
the accounts
i'm happy to any questions councillor
atkinson
thank you ma'am just outside this report
if it um
uh rural provincial just some time ago i
can't even remember that was it seems
like about five years ago but i think it
was only probably a couple of months
there was a suggestion from some of the
other
tas that audit had indicated to them
that they don't have enough resource to
do the end-of-year audits on time
putting which is rather interesting
because that's one of the
things they check councils on is that
they're on time of course and you get
back down if you're not but they can't
do it on time
have we had any indication from audit
new zealand that
we are in that position or are we in
still in the position which is favorable
to us
uh no we we we're getting audited on
time for ourselves the parent which is
the council but
for enc in tikohaka
they have been delayed the audits until
november so normally we would prepare
these
on a pretty finalized draft because the
associates need to be audited and
adopted before the
end of september normally
so we'll do the same but we'll prepare
the accounts based on their drafts
because of the amount of turnover those
two entities have
it doesn't have a significant effect on
our accounts if say they have an error
of
a hundred thousand so we'll we'll do
that on that basis
where we might get an effect is when
they do an ltp
audit which is later on in december
but once again because we've got an
audit on our annual report
it shouldn't have too much of an effect
even if we were audited late
so no no no effects on our accounts at
all it's
um according to them it's been an easy
audit so far
everything's up to date and
it should it should be ready for
adoption early october
so just clarification around that the
fact that tikohaka
in in horizontal canterbury will be late
audited
by them how does that tick the on time
box for us given us the is that stated
in there because
personally i think it's something that
should be and i just wonder if that's
yep so there's a legislation's given
them exemption
so they won't get a tag on their
accounts they'll have to note that it's
that they've got an exemption so won't
have any effect on our accounts at all
we'll once again
we'll put a note in our accounts that
they've been based on a draft
under legislation that's been approved
any other questions as counselor at
redwood
thanks jeff on page 51
um an interest register for senior
management
is it proposed excuse me i've
i've been given something to choose um
is it proposed to have a register for
senior management and if so when
yes so that was uh discussed at
the management team meeting two weeks
ago
and senior managers have now
required to put in your interests into a
register which
i'm pretty sure just about every manager
has done now and there's a register that
exists for that
um and putting uh registering that you
have no interests is just
uh as is registering and an interest and
that's one of the things that i've put
in personally
that i have no interest but i have also
gone further to state that i
know what my property and other dealings
have been
throughout the district and memberships
and finally who will have access to the
register
uh the only one that's got access to it
at the moment is the chief executive
and the executive assistants
i assume that it will probably go on to
the management team agenda at some stage
for viewing and i'm not sure what
the chief executives
he's going to do he might put that in
front of the council as well just
as a matter of interest
thank you no further questions
councillors
councillor atkinson moves um a to d
second councillor williams oh the mayor
council williams discussion council at
concern
look just to say well done again um it's
good to see that we've
acted quickly on the on the points that
are that have been pointed out to us
um and that uh we're obviously making
good progress this sets up
very well for the uh for the end of year
um audits
so well done to you and your team jeff
and
we will await the final order to see
where we're at so
thank you any further comment
no um all right i'll put item 5.1
all those in favor please say i against
the cleric carried thank you um item 5.2
is health and safety audit results for
june
and we welcome a katrina blake new
safety and
help health and safety coordinator
welcome
really far away hi all right if you
could take us through the report that
would be great
thank you atamarie councillors uh madam
chair
um nice to see you again um so i
would just like to introduce katrina
blake i think this is katrina's first
time at the audit and risk committee
meeting
so katrina is our um if you don't know
health and safety coordinator and she
was responsible for
putting together the report and the
audit findings as well so
she will be able to answer any technical
questions that you have around the
report findings or anything that's
happened
since then so um the report in front of
you
details the audits that were completed
in june
this year they focused on asbestos
handling and disposal
plant and equipment maintenance and safe
working in the field
overall the results were very pleasing
for us this is an internally produced
audit that we complete
to maintain compliance
against not only our internal processes
and procedures but we also cross
reference them against work safe
guidelines a tree
katrina is qualified to complete these
audits she's fully trained in this area
and i'll take the rest of the report as
read and open up for any questions that
you might have
thank you thank you um any questions
council
speakers um christmas thank you
i'm just interested in this asbestos
handling and removal would you just like
to just give me a little bit more of a
heads up on how this works and how you
you
how you you hand
okay definitely not handle it
so we have a component of our
organisation the water unit that
the the ones that typically go out and
do all of the asbestos
handling when it comes to just pipe work
so
they have a safe operating procedure
that they use to
do the the types of work that they do
with that pipe work or however they
might find it
so the audit was to
step by step walk through that process
as an observer with the team
um to ensure that they were adhering to
everything that's required
under the health and safety act for
asbestos management handling with the
training that they've had
so um it was seamless so yeah
it's good because um there was a
question where i was asking was with the
water units
um finding these old types of pipes
so for for removal of them
what is the process for doing that so
they if you go right back to
the the start they have to um go through
a process to find out what
what other services are in there as well
so they do know that there's old pipe
work in there the ac pipes that
contain asbestos very low amount of
asbestos
but if they are disturbed they can allow
portions of particles to go into the
potable water
and saying that though once it goes in
there and it's wet it's not really
um it's not a concern to the public or
anything like that but we don't like it
to go in there so we do follow a process
that
when they change those pipes out
there's two types of ways that they do
it they can use chain cutters to cut
that pipe which it essentially is the
most safest way to do it because it just
cracks the pipe
onto some um whatever they're actually
using to
put underneath them depending on the
nature of the trench that they're in
and it that captures the particles they
crack it with the chain
and they just remove that piece of pipe
and then they sleeve it with a new
ac pipe so there's no
[Music]
no leaks or anything like that they
leave them there if they're not
damaged because that they don't create
an issue but if they find a leak then
they only take the section that they
need to take
it's all bagged and taken away properly
thank you very much you're welcome
just around that um is there a disposal
area in our district for
uh for asbestos because
i don't think we do it do we at the
refrigerators we
have a disposal method down at the water
unit where there's a proper bin and
that's taken away by waste management i
believe
cape valley has a proper area yeah so
once it's contained there it's removed
so is that open to residents or is that
just purely
with our own internal it's our own
residents cannot drive in their night
that's where basically
our land landfall and everything that
sorted goes to yeah
so all these residents sorry i'm just
thinking of the future is what i'm doing
all our residents have to actually go to
christchurch to dispose of asbestos
yes there are a couple of places in
christchurch that you can go to but if
they're not sure they can ask at south
brook
it's checked as they go on the gate so
you can't um
dump anything thank you um
i just have a question myself uh um uh
the the graph that's on page
uh uh that no yeah three or five but
uh plant and equipment maintenance where
you've got a
41 non-compliance and and the comment
that um
some departments are currently working
on establishing um their new
schedules um to ensure all assets are
maintained
thoroughly and improvement in compliance
is is that snapshot that you've taken
there
is that a concern overall
no it's actually very good we
considering we've got some projects at
the moment where our assets are being
loaded into
through the amos project so a lot of the
non-compliant is because it's not quite
there yet so we can't
say that it's compliant because we're
not using we're not functioning with
that system yet
but there's a lot of work going on with
the assets
and they will be in an asset management
system where
all of the assets will have their own
dates when they need to be maintained
who they're maintained by what
legislative requirements
and what manufacturers specifications
have to be followed so it's in the works
and it's a lot better than what we've
had
coming through say up until now
so and what um what time frame would you
expect before
i think they're past the testing phase
the water unit i'm not sure
um jeff if you can elaborate with that
but they
i think they're almost up and running um
the only thing they're not putting on it
is the pipes because it's under
wire maps in a different area but um
they are
um almost ready to hit the go button
yeah
so the next time so then when would you
next
look at um doing this sort of review
is it a annual or is it more frequently
i think i'd like it if it was annual but
i do it six monthly
so i'll probably look at doing it around
october
because we will have things up and
running by then so it'll be good to do
another snapshot
probably won't be as robust but just a
snapshot of
how that process is actually working and
where our non-compliances are sitting so
we can hone in on that a small portion
of the non-compliance
is with the pdu um they don't have a lot
of equipment that needs
to be maintained all the time but what
they do have
they don't have on a register so
i can't really go and make it a
compliance if they're not checking it
on an annual six-month three-month basis
so
they're working on that but they only
have a small portion of equipment that
needs to be checked and it's mainly
around
traffic management cool okay
thank you any other questions
councillors
um no well i'm happy uh to move
and council atkinson is aesthetic and
seconding
any any discussion or
i'll just say yeah welcome um this
update
and certainly would the one that
struck me as you know too much of that
orange color
and i would certainly welcome an
improvement next time you do it
um yes i guess you can councilwords
um we move out some of our buildings
because they're not up to the um
the right standards and we're renting
some properties
are we checking to make sure they're at
a
uh an adequate level of um safety
before we move staff into them yes
talking about
building strength and athletes yeah yeah
yes
so are you talking about the temporary
accommodation at the moment so all of
those buildings have been checked
and they all come within within the code
that's required for them to be housed in
so yeah they were checked before any of
the staff went in them
they're into the code that we require
for our own building
correct an example of that was the main
building here
where it was sitting at 40 percent and
we put in that nine meter
beam and locked it into the end of the
western walls
and that took it above 67 so we wouldn't
uh weren't
putting the staff in there until that
was fixed so that's been now fixed and
that was the one we had the most uh
concern over
and yeah
mr may and then council of duty just
just briefly um very good report um
katrina and i
i'd like to officially welcome you in
your new role
um and congratulate you on achieving
that we
very much look forward to working with
you
because it's a really important role
within our council we certainly
had a really good relationship with with
charlotte and
certainly appreciated working with um
with her and i'm sure
we'll be the same with you so we look
forward to your regular updates here and
thanks for your first report well thank
you very much for your kind words
and i've been happy to um assist with
filling the gap until the new health and
safety manager arrives
she's our coordinator tips in the future
mia that would be um
something i would look into but uh
apologies what kind words
i had assumed that you were in from the
title
apologies something i hope to aim to in
the future
yes well my apologies also because i
thought you were it was a nice boost for
the day
thank you thank you councilman
i'm just going to just say much the same
as the me except me i won't put my foot
in it
but i'd just like to say just like to
say thank you very much for this
report it's excellent um well done
indeed yes
and i'll probably come and it might
email you with one or two little things
i just want to question at some stage
absolutely i really appreciate the uh
your report and it very detailed thank
you
pleasure thank you all right any other
comments questions no it's been moved
and seconded so i'll put it all those in
favor atc
now please say aye against declare it
carriage
thank you very much anyone would like to
come and visit us we are now in the
parkside portacom
you're welcome to come over for a coffee
yes that is our new
home i will be there
absolutely thank you thank you
um item we move on to item 5.3 which is
the non-financial performance measures
um pages 66-83 and welcome helene
thank you helene if you would like to
take us
through your report so
uh the report for the financial year
ending 30 june 2020
i can't hear you
so overall the results were consistent
with the previous year which is quite
pleasing considering
um a number of the measures were
affected by
the lockdown mainly
a number of meetings that weren't held
surveys that would have been
conducted during the last quarter and a
number of official meetings that weren't
held
so we could have been in excess of last
year's result
so other than that i'll take the report
as read and any questions
any questions counselors
uh councillor redmond
ah thank you helene am i correct in
assuming under the summary on page 84
where there were three areas of uh
non-compliance or failure to meet
targets
that those matters are really outside
the council's control
and we're the result of covert lockdowns
and other
interruptions oh sorry
you're on the wrong way yeah am i on the
wrong report
yes we're behind you
we're on the um i'll withdraw that
question
all right
no paul is a paul is still there and
any other any questions counselors
our counselor atkinson moves and
councillor williams
seconds thank you councilman
i just look just thank you for this i
know it's been a very awkward time
trying to get to
get results from things that have been
in
the lockdown or other things that have
happened so it's a very good result
for uh for what we have here and we'll
we'll wait with baited breath once all
the restrictions come off and see what
uh see where we're at which will
probably be within a couple of days so
there we go or not
all right council williamson no
all right um i'll no further discussion
i will put the report
a to d all those in favor please say i
against declare it carried thank you
helene
and we move on to item 5.4 pages 84
to 128 and welcome paul
to the table for the financial report
for the
period ending june 30th thank you
yeah this report's presenting the
preliminary result
for the council's finances for the year
i'm just noting new zealand's at the
moment and the process for the final
order
and that is the
bulk of the fieldwork's meant to be
finished at the end of next week
so that the annual report can be adopted
oh jeff what's the date does it for its
date in october nothing is the fourth
fourth yeah
[Music]
it's the
the surplus was 2.8 million um against
the budget of 20.5 million
um item 4.2 in the report um
explains the major reasons for
that variance um the
council's debt was its 160 external debt
was at 160 million
at the end of the year and that was
against a budget of 185 million
um just to note in the first three
months of
this financial year we won't be raising
any further
external debt
[Music]
and the capital program spend was 50.5
million
there's a report further report coming
to council i believe
to give more detail on that
and the uh
just i might just quickly go through um
item 4.2 which has the
explanation of the variances for the
surplus
the major items are the interest rate
swaps
accounting valuation this is
the last two years in a row we've had
this as the because we're
locked into interest rate hedges
as the interest rates have been falling
that's meant we've had to do an
accounting
valuation adjustment at the end of the
year i'm down
the development contribution revenue was
under budget by 6.2 million
that we've indicated that that was going
to happen right through the year
the ended ta subsidies were under
revenue
because the the capital program was
behind we only get that
as the cap as the capital was spent
and two items that pretty much we have
every year which is the um the
accounting for assets disposed as
part of renewals work was three million
and the
expenditure which was budgeted as
capital but needs to be accounted for is
operating which was 4.1 million
and i'll take the rest of the report as
read and because there's no one
reporting it
the 4.6 there is confidential
amount that we'll just sorry
oh okay
okay okay i can't disguise
some questions questions and then
councillor redmond this is the right
white one councilman just under your
which is
one of the most helpful pieces of
measures we get here which is the
financial bid at the start
paul um i just want to we're getting up
to 10.8
percent unfavorable not operating costs
is that is a fair bit of that due to the
um the building and shifting people
around or is there
another explanation for sort of 10.8
percent i mean i know that we covered in
there and things
um well uh again on the item 4.2
there's basically three of the items in
there uh
yeah so this is the accounting valuation
adjustment of 5.5
the uh the assets disposed for renewals
and the um expenditure budget is capital
but
which has to be accounted for is
operating those three items
come to about 12.6 million and that's
the
that's the difference
uh council redmond ryan my question will
come as no surprise paul
the three areas of non-compliance my
conclusion was
that covert and external factors were
largely responsible for those is that a
correct sort of
conclusion
um well i suppose you could say covered
in that
one of the reasons why the interest
rates have dropped so dramatically
is the response to the recession
that's come as a result of covert the
external factors i suppose you could say
the
development contribution revenue is
largely driven by
how fast the developers are developing
so
that's not an item we can really
control very much yeah
any is that satisfactory counselor
regardless
yes madam chair i think the external
fact is covert seems to be behind
the economy um interest rates
development contribution so i mean
we don't really have any control over a
lot of
those uh areas
have a question um about the
um you say we're having a report on the
capital program
which is underspent um in your note here
on in 4.2
the nzta subsidies
that attach with that capital works
program
do we lose those if in fact we're
under spent and don't use them within
the 12 months
um enzyme tay uh nzta work on a three
year program
um and uh this year was year two of that
program
okay so um if we get uh that's why the
the roading budget for this year has
remained
higher as we um and we've reduced
while we've reduced some of the other
budgets um to try and
complete some of that work that we've
got
been approved for subsidy yes i
just also i mean i don't know whether
it's part of your responsibilities but
if we are underspent to this degree
what is the likelihood that in year
three i mean this is what we
we looked at earlier um that we are
going to
um to to be able to
use that or spend spend the capital
we've said we're
going to and and get that full ncta
subsidy
um yeah well jeff might want to answer a
bit further but
um that when we set the budget this year
we did basically
and the utilities and roading area they
have basically dropped
the budgets in in all three waters areas
and the only one that they've kept it up
is the roading one
so that there was a going to be a
concentration of the work on the rating
program yeah just one more question i
just want to ask that
the data that we went into the annual
plan with which was
we were under spent but we were going to
have a good go at it in
year three is is where we are now
um reflecting the information
correctly that we went into budget with
uh yeah actually they
were behind yeah if you look at the uh
report we had from march
um the capital got it with the yeah the
forecast that we had
at march particularly for the roading
area um
where we ended up was was pretty close
to um where the where the prediction was
at march
so we're on track um yeah well we were
um yeah given we're in the position that
we thought we would be at gene
when we were okay forecasting in march
yeah thank you
thank you i was just going to confirm
that what paul was saying is correct
we carried that budget over from um this
year
or last year until this year that's
pushed our capital works program up
quite considerably now the subsidies
from
nzta coming through with that so it's
just a
carryover of the two there was a report
provided to the council which showed
what the completion rate would likely be
for this year and i think that was
around about the
mid-80s and contrary to
audit new zealand and i've commented on
the amount of work that
councils complete in each year
we've already identified as about 15
it's just out of our control
completely but we have to put it in
there
to make sure we account for some of the
development work
we're a little bit different to our
council which doesn't have a lot of
growth
we still have a lot of growth and we're
still forecasting that we're going to
have
uh growth even with covert in existence
just because of our
uh circumstances we've got
the likelihood that we're going to grow
in at least 500
new dwellings this year which is
contrary to a lot of other districts
in their growth so yes we have got a
large capital west program but it's
uh we've already forecasted that it'll
probably be about 15
uncomplete thank you council award
i just wanted to reconfirm it or just
ask i think you've answered my question
paul
that's where um everything has for this
year
been um planned so that we achieve
and and get the completion within three
years is that correct
well especially with nzta
yeah but as i said before the
um the plan was to drop the
budgets for three waters
so that's been a lot of work being
deferred in those areas
which frees up time staff time to
concentrate on the roading
program all right counselor duty
i'm just uh i'm just looking at the uh
district council
year-to-date revenue and expenditure and
i think perhaps jeff's
answered that one is that we're waiting
you're waiting on that land trade
land transport new zealand's um subsidy
to come through
is that what that's showing because it's
showing the red yes
yes that's right yeah yeah yeah um we're
showing that the
capital works for road complete yeah so
we didn't get the subsidies for that and
we didn't have to raise the loans for
that work so we've
carried that forward into the current
year yeah i've got yeah i thought that
was
the case but i just want to double check
on that thank you
all right any further questions um a
mover who would like to move it
the mayor would like to move it i think
you see what
and council award would love to second
it i know
thank you discussion mr mayor
council award excellent any further
comment
no um i'll just say that
this is a this is a challenging
budget year we've put ourselves to
and um i really
don't want to see and i think it has
happened in the past where we have lost
our
nz ta subsidy because we didn't
complete the capital works and we don't
want to be
in that position again i don't think it
happens very often but it certainly has
happened
so we just need to keep
keep our foot on the accelerator because
our staff have said they're going to
achieve this challenging program and
we are there to make sure that happens
so thank you
i'll put this um
this motion all those in favor please
say i
against declare it carried thank you
and we move on to item six which is
portfolio
updates and uh we have council award
with order risk long term plan and
excellence program
council lord thank you very much
um quite a quite a lot in the last two
months we've had several long-term plan
meetings
uh just getting underway with those of
waimakariri visitors strategy review
workshops
on going stadium project
group which is coming along
nicely and up to date
also the accommodation refurbishment
group i'm about to meet with rob
to look at colours and things as things
get underway
three workshops um waters workshop
and christchurch and kaipoi covert 19
recovery plan workshop
and dpnr meetings um joint
ecan meetings greater christchurch
partnership
50-year plan reviews joint
promotions meetings time centers
lighting meetings
as well as the community boards and then
the ranger airfield advisory group
very happy to say that the designation
for the airfield has been
finally approved excellent council award
thank you for a comprehensive report
any questions of council award
no i was thinking that myself
um thank you um 6.2 is
is communications customer service and
we don't have seem to have councillor
barnard here um
is she oh okay
was it there's an apology for council
violet was sent through to
this morning oh okay how could we record
yes thank you i'm happy to second all
those in favor please say aye
thank you um yes we didn't have that
when we opened the meeting but that's
all good
all right um we'll move on then to
um item seven which is questions i have
none
you haven't heard from barry cuttings
have we no
okay um
all right yes all right
well it is oxford after all um
no we'll move on to um
item 8 urgent general business no
agent general business so now we'll move
over
stop stop laughing
we'll move into committee um for
the i think it's just the minutes
actually
so i'll put that um we move into public
excluded
um to consider the minutes of
um the july and the 21st meeting
um i'll move it councillor atkinson will
second
all those in favor please say i will
move into